-I want to talk about the show
because it's very much
a change of pace for you, but
also want to talk about this
It's very exciting.
You got to go to
"The Lion King" premiere.
-Yeah.
-Because your father was
the director of photography.
Your father is a very --
Caleb, there, is a very famous
Oscar-nominated cinematographer.
And so you got to go.
What was it like,
the experience of going?
-It's a hot ticket.
-It is a hot ticket.
-It's a hot ticket. Okay.
This was the first time that
a group of people
got to see the movie,
so it was so much security
We had to go in.
They took our phones and the
put them in these little pouches
that you can't open them.
And the movie didn't start for
an hour and a half
after it was supposed to start
-Yeah.
-People were going insane.
-Including me.
-Right.
No, I can't even imagine.
-I didn't even get a chance to
text my husband saying like,
"I won't have my phone."
So I'm thinking like, "What if
there's an emergency?"
So you don't have your phone
We were forced to talk wit
human beings.
-I know. That's awful.
-Which is very strange.
-It sounds terrible, yeah.
-It's very strange.
My sister kept having,
like, an alarm go off,
and she'd have to, like,
press the button
on the side every five minutes
-This sounds like it was
a weird, like,
trap for wealthy people.
Like, "Unfortunately, there will
not be a film tonight."
-That's what it felt like.
That's what it felt like.
But it was ama-- And, you know
Beyoncé was there.
That's how my dad sold it to us.
Like he'd have to sell it, like,
to come to this amazing film
-So your dad,
who worked on the film,
had to say to you guys, "You
might see Beyoncé,"
to get you to go?
-"You might get to meet
Beyoncé."
-That's great.
That sounds like a normal thin
to tell daughters
that are like 6 and 8.
-Right, right.
But I am a huge Beyoncé fan.
I've seen her in concert.
I mean, who isn't?
-Right.
-Right? Okay?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
But -- And I -- You know,
I mean, she came --
There was literally a standing
ovation for her just being her
-Just being there. Yeah.
-Right.
She came in, and I had a clear
view of her the whole movie,
which was very -- I mean, I wa
watching the movie, of course.
-Right.
-But I was also watching
Beyoncé.
At like 3/4 of the way through
my sister leans in and is like
"Beyoncé's right there,
and she's smiling."
Like, "I'm watching her
the whole time.
What do you think
I've been watching?
I'm watching her face."
And She's smiling.
She's loving it.
-That's a good question.
Like, what is a movie
that's so good
that you won't watch
Beyoncé watching?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Like, what's better?
That movie or watching it just
like, reflect in her eyes?
-Well, I can also...
[ Laughs ]
And I literally had like
that much of her face.
Like, it was like this much.
I don't know how much
you can see,
but it was like that much,
you know?
And it was very satisfying
-You should have gotten
together with, like --
found the other people who had
the different
angles of her face and
then talked afterwards
and be like, "I can tell you
what this part did."
And they were like,
"Oh, this part loved it."
Yeah.
-Oh, totally.
I was -- The movie is amazing.
-Great.
-Amazing.
-That's awesome.
-So, it was --
I did watch the movie, too
-And then, when it was over an
everybody got their phones out
was it just, like, madness
the speed at which people
were like...
[ Imitates beeping ]
-It was, but I was very
disappointed that
I really didn't get many
texts or e-mails.
-Yeah.
-You know, like, I think I got
like, a sale or something.
I was expecting, like,
some big thing to happen.
-And they were like,
"Something big did happen.
Pottery Barn wants to
let you know --"
-20% off this one stool.
Yeah, something like that.
But, yeah, it was --
You don't feel as cool,
yeah, when you don't get
as many e-mails.
But, I mean, liter--
I mean, it was hours,
because it didn't start fo
an hour --
I mean, it was at least
three hours.
I can do some math.
I don't know.
A movie is an hour and a half,
two hours?
-I bet when Beyoncé took her
out of her pocket,
it had just, like,
burned to a, like --
It was just like shrapnel.
It was like
too many texts came through.
It was like too much happened,
and it blew up in the bag.
-Exploded.
-Yeah.
-I feel like she might not hav
had to put it in that thing.
-Yeah. Oh, you think?
-There are different rules
for Beyoncé.
-Right, right.
-And I'm okay with that.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I'm really okay with that
-That's true.
"Hey, Bey, we need you to pu
your phone in a pouch."
"Okay. Oh, that's fine.
Would you like to put
my phone in a pouch?"